uh hello everyone i am ganur
actually i'm a phd camp at balls
university in istanbul and now i'm
visiting phd researcher at utrecht
university and my advisors are generous
grand co-advisors
and in ins talk i will share a gandalf
message
about changing privacy
so let's assume that
frodo wants to
share a content in his online social
network accounts
uh what kind of contents uh
let's let's think that
this content can be
an image of a ring
but
gandalfs
do not
doesn't think that this is a great idea
why because
maybe
this sharing action
uh can have some catastrophic
consequences like if
frodo shares this image
in his online social network account and
then maybe
his life will be in danger
because
maybe there are some bad people or some
evil eyes
desire this ring so online social
networks enable users to share content
online with others
but in in this case users need to manage
their privacy while sharing activity
and
these kind of
activities require more efforts to
detect to observe elements that the
content contains and these are time
consuming
and error prone so we need a system we
need to have a system that recommends
privacy labels
instead of a user
and accurately
and and
um and in literature most of the
existing ebro approach are uh
centralized which means that they use
the data which has
which has shared by many users
and
one important aspect of the privacy is
subjectivity so
a content
can be identified as a private
by certain individuals but others do not
think that this is a private content so
um
we need a
subjective approach i i mean
yeah we need a
we need this kind of approach
and
we do not have access all of
people's data
but always i have access my own data so
we need to have a system to preserve our
privacy that recommends price labels
uh for a given content by learning its
users privacy preferences
and then one it won its user uh whether
the content is uh
public or private
so we propose a
an approach uh which is patch price
estimation from short history it's
agent-based approach which means that
each of the online social network users
is represented by an agent
and
we can yeah pagex can access on the
user's data
and
when
the system relies on only small data set
i mean if
the system use only user's data which
means that it is on small it uses small
data set while classifying content in
machine learning uh in in this is a
this is better than
a centralized approach because uh we
need to preserve privacy of online
social network users and we only
we have only access to the user's data
so
our aim is
we are trying to predict labels of a new
image
so
yeah for this task we make use of tfrf
term-free considerable spherical method
i think tfidf is more popular right
maybe you are familiar with tfidf it is
a
sister of brother of df idea it's tfrf
and we use tfrf because
we we care about the
frequency of
tags
i will mention about text frequency of
text in public and private images i mean
um yeah we use term frequency relevance
frequency
methods and in this method in in our
system each image has 20 different tags
which are
descriptive text about images
tags are constructed by
users
or
generated by tools like clarify so
in in this approach we have images and
we have 20 different texts for each
image
which are describe these images
and in this formula we have yeah
actually basically uh we have some uh
terms like rs and tf uh
these denotes basically the number of
occurrences of a selected tag in all
images in all public images in all
private images and then other term is a
other term counts the number of
occurrences of a selected tag
in a specific image so um
the the benefits of
this method is like
you have public images you have private
images and you have tags for each images
and
you
prepare your input for the classifier
using this method
how using this formula and i will show a
sample scenario
after this slide and then yes in here
you count the number of occurrences in
public and private image in in the
relevant images
and
yes
yeah
and these are the
popular vector representations actually
we have image we have we have text for d
for images
and
we can use tfrf method uh to
represent uh
images as a vector like
or
we can also uh use vector
representations like word embedding
methods uh to
to create a vector to to represent uh
images in as a vector format like
uh each take
using these word embedding methods you
can also have a vector representation
for each tag
and you then you can combine tags uh for
each image
and in here yeah we have birth in in the
literature we have bird embedding word
to the xory
and glo
and using these uh
word embedding methods actually we we
can create a feature vectors
uh
like uh yeah future vectors and then use
them as a as an input for the classifier
and
since the learning is done
[Music]
maybe some text has not seen in the
training phase at the training phase
in this case we do not have any
representation for on syntax so in in
patch
we propose a
similar text using cosine similarity
metric it means if the take has not seen
in the training phase but we have in the
test phase uh we find the the most
similar tag for this on syntax
based on a cosine similarity metric
so yeah this is a sample scenario
let's let's assume that we have three
different online social network users
like on the left side and then
in in this method in in this proposed
approach actual patch
we have a software agent for each of the
user
and um
let's say
one of our user has three different
images and
these images have
four
tags in in this sample scenario
okay
okay um let's say one of user has three
different images
and
all of the three images has a
five different tags
and
the the agent of the user can reach
these images it's their labels
and tags
so
this agent knows everything about its
users user can share user shares
every information with the agent
and
and then this user has two new images
and tags are
yeah you you have shown the text in in
this slide
and
um
yeah in the previous images we have uh
adult child fun one
uh something like
something like these texts but in here
we have girl tag and this tag has not
seen in these in previous images so um
this is new for us yeah this is new for
that agent
so
uh
using patch we can
recommend
the most similar tag with the url tech
which is woman using cosine similarity
metric
and
these are the
matrices actually inputs for the machine
learning classifier
uh for for this example actually we have
five images in here three of them are
for training uh phase the
two of them are for the test phase
and in here
we construct actually this
at this step we uh
we
count the number of occurrences that
take is take occurs in the public and
private images
and columns
correspond to the text like we have
adult child concert blah blah blah woman
and those correspond to the images we
have five images so we have five rows
and at the bottom uh
we
we construct matrices using uh public
images i mean uh adult yeah the first
image uh in the matter is one one index
uh the first image has adult tech and
adult tech
occurs uh only one time in public images
so the the cell value the index uh
is the one
and you can um
you can use the same logic to complete
all of the cells of the metrics and
this one is for uh
this one keeps uh
the occurrences uh
among the private images and then using
tf rf formula
uh we uh calculate the the weight of
tags actually we assign uh we assign
the assign weight value using tf rf
method to to each tag
and takes our uh
yeah takes our represent uh
take takes represents the the images
yeah
we use a subset of piccolo dataset uh
piccolo dataset consists of filical
images on various topics
and
which are
labeled as public or private by external
viewers
and
in here actually you have shown
an example
for public and private classes on the
left side you show the public class
example and this one is
for private class and you showed the
20 different tags for each images and
these are
really descriptive and these texts are
created using by clarify app
yes in in our simulation we have 59
agents
and as an uh as a classifier as a
learning algorithm we use random force
with a hundred estimators
uh we have epsilon value actually in
tfra formula in the previous cfra
formula in the original one we do not
have epsilon value but
if the take does not occur in public or
private classes so we have a division by
zero problem so we add epsilon value
which is very close to zero
and we have cosine similarity threshold
because uh we we can recommend new we
can recommend attack
for
on syntax
and
we can
determine we can define the threshold
value for the similarity i mean
if the similarity of the tags bigger
than 0.7 yes it's very similar for me so
you can recommend this tag to to do on
syntax uh yeah
and we execute our uh
our scripts uh 10 times and take the
average of the results
yeah i use python
[Laughter]
as expected
yeah i really like python
these are the diaries pandas knife numpy
scikit-learn pickle matte random
system nltk forward and meetings we have
burden birth emitting
library and if you want to use tfidf
model you can use gansim
and so on i i also use met plot but i
i forget
yeah so
yeah
you can use every yeah these libraries
for for this
work or you can
uh
i don't know
and i picked some results for this
approach for the performance for for
uh for showing the performance of the
our proposed approach page
uh yes we can
prepare inputs using word and medic
methods like birth glob or virtualet or
we use
tfidf sorry tf rf method
uh to assign a
weight value for for text
and
uh if we
uh recommend um
a tag
a tag for the on syntax uh this is page
so you can show the performance of the
uh
of different approach in here and so
out of the yeah if we do not recommend
any tags uh for the on syntax the
performance is a very similar
is the same actually uh for for the
accuracy uh metric uh
globe vertweg and tfrf but if we
recommend
a new tag not new
if we recommend a tag from our training
data set
for the unseen tech and the performance
is increasing yeah for
uh all of the metrics
and
yeah this is enough yeah
yeah the
we we rank the tax uh
um
in the frequency of relevant classes
like public and private classes so
yellow ones are uh for public class uh
and google ones are for private class uh
you show the most frequently used text
on the x-axis
and
you you show the frequency of the text
on the y-axis so i think this is
important for me because yeah i really
like this
result because
when we look at this result we show that
people tag is more frequently used in
the public classes but
yeah
actually these are the most frequently
used texts but
most frequently use takes for public and
private classes so these are common
texts for our classes and uh yeah people
is used in private classes more than
public classes but it's very common tech
for both classes and like for women
it's also
like a private class tax because uh the
ratio of the private class and public
class is
uh yeah the the difference is huge for
the woman tag
and yes um yeah some takes are um more
frequently used in
in a relevant class so this shows uh
this difference this similarity or
this information
actually this is a
work and we
we published a workshop paper in ai for
privacy
workshop so if you want to get more
information about this work you can scan
this code and
go to website and
find the pdf version of the whole work
that's all for my presentation if you
have any questions or comments or
feedbacks i would like to
answer all of them thank you for
listening
[Applause]
uh
thank you for your talk
and um we have one question online and
then
i'll give it again to the room okay um
two questions okay uh instead of
replacing singleton tags with its
closest one wouldn't it be possible to
sum the embeddings of all terms in a
pick to get a feature vector uh
yeah can you repeat your question after
the okay can you repeat
yes instead of replacing singleton tags
with its closest one wouldn't it be
possible to sum the embeddings of all
terms in a pick to get a feature vector
for for the tag or
i don't get uh the point
um
is this question
uh
is this your okay then i'll give you the
mic
yeah actually yeah yeah
you
you can do this
hi thanks very talk great talk um
so the second question was also mine so
are you okay
maybe this should have been the first
question so how do you compute uh the
future representation using uh large
language models using large language
models so you compare your baselines are
uh bird and yes yes more than meeting
methods yeah yes
[Music]
but then you have this um
this table right
where you showed the metrics of the
other
performance uh yeah that one yeah okay
so when you use these approaches how do
you compute the feature vectors for your
pictures
so yeah we have an image we have 20
different tags
and each tag can yeah
we have a vector representation for each
tech using word embedding methods like
one of them like glow has 200
dimensional uh vector or birth has
different
dimensional vectors so we have feature
vectors and then we can combine we we
combine
20 different
vectors
to get only one okay feature vector
itunes yes okay there's so many devices
okay that was a question yeah okay
perfect
thanks
um okay second question
what does the name
stand for
yes
this
privacy estimation from short history
because we only use users data so we
have small data sets and we only use the
past experiences we only learn
features or learn
sharing behaviors on the user's past
experiences
so we use short history
and
yeah
okay any question from the audience in
the room
first you then i come to you
yes my question thank you for
for your presentation yes
my question
is
do you recommend a privacy or a public
tag
but um you said at the beginning that um
it has a subjective point of view so has
the user the
a
last will to say okay yeah the pesh
has recommended me to
tag this photo as private but i think
it's a public one so i would like to
learn
i mean is there a feedback loop where
right now no
but it would be a great idea yeah it
would be nice
okay thank you capable of this this
thing yeah right now we do not have any
feedback mechanism like this but in the
future
thank you
uh hi so yeah great talk again uh this
was really really interesting from that
table for with the results with the
precision f1 and recall and accuracy
i'm surprised that bert got the lowest
results there given that it's if you
into an lp it's like the that thing that
everybody should be using right
so
i was curious uh
how exactly did he use birth in this
because birth provides like vectors with
a context right given a sentence yes uh
but did you apply it like on the single
word and then use that vector
or did you provide like a chunk of of
words or tags i don't know exactly how
you use it to get those vectors because
if you use glove or word to back et
cetera like it doesn't have context so
i'm very surprised by the results yes
actually yeah thank you that's a very
great question uh i use for birth i use
this this one pre
which yeah i use birth
model
vertebrating model uh who's trained on
contextualized
version
and you can reach
this
from this
so um
the result i think the result depends on
the preterite models
i mean uh for the second one i use a
model who uh trained on the google news
corpus
um actually none of them are pre trained
on a private
news or private documents
so
the performance of the bird were to wake
glove
depends
based on
their
pre-trained
documents
yeah birth is
a birth yields very
great performance and yields better
performance other popular methods in
literature
and when i use this version
contextualized word embedding model
so
i can get
the results on the table so it depends
on the pre-trained documents
any more questions we have enough time
for questions
i don't see anyone raising their hand so
um i think we're done uh thank you again
for uh your presentation for answering
questions and thank you for being here
and
yeah
have fun at
lunch
thank you